One of the hardest things when you're trying to effect change...
...is that people like this gentleman are right in some areas.
And, one of the things I've always found is...
...that you've got to start with the customer experience...
...and work backwards to the technology.
You can't start with the technology...
...and try to figure out where you're gonna try to sell it,...
...and I've made this mistake probably more than anybody else in this room.
And as we have tried to come up with a strategy and a vision for Apple,...
...it started with, "What incredible benefits can we give to the customer?"
"Where can we take the customer?"
Not starting with, "Let's sit down with the engineers"...
..."and figure out what awesome technology we have"...
..."and then how are we gonna market that?"
And I think that's the right path to take.
There's a whole lot of people working super, super hard right now at Apple.
The whole team is working, burning the midnight oil,...
...and they're doing their best.
Some mistakes will be made along the way.
That's good because at least some decisions are being made along the way...
...and we'll find the mistakes, we'll fix them.
Mistakes we made, some people will be pissed off,...
...some people will not know what they're talking about,...
...but I think it is so much better than where things were not very long ago.
And I think we're gonna get there.